thanks hugh jackman you simultaneously
make me want to workout more while also
making me feel incredibly inferior about
my body the Wolverine is directed by
james mangold that was stupid this movie
is a second try at telling a Wolverine
centric film x-men origins Wolverine
wasn't very well accepted by fans or
critics I didn't dig the film personally
I am however a fan of the first two
x-men films as well as x-men first class
x-men 3 no but I was pretty hopeful
about this movie because it goes along
the storyline that takes place in Japan
samurais ninjas the Wolverine learning
to be the Wolverine again because we
open in this movie he's extremely broken
about the death of gene he has basically
gone into hiding he hasn't done any type
of hero things in a long time he wants
to just be a loner because he feels like
everything that he loves or cares for
eventually is killed and so he feels as
if he doesn't really have a place in the
world anymore until a person that he
helped out once in the past gives him
the opportunity to perhaps become mortal
and when he's offered this opportunity
we get to see Logan go through a
personal struggle that we haven't seen
him go through in any of the x-men films
there's also a girl that he's getting to
know that sort of on the hinge of
becoming more the most wealthiest and
powerful women in Japan she has a lot of
assassins after her and he's trying to
protect her all of this is happening in
Japan around all this mythology and
ancient Japanese customs that really
make the Wolverine the Wolverine movie
that I was hoping x-men origins was I
was very surprised how much I enjoyed
this film I really actually kind of dug
it quite a bit The Wolverine is a really
badass movie as the movie opened you
could tell that James Mangold was going
to direct this movie very differently
this is not your conventional comic book
film at all this feels very serious all
of the characters are taking these
things extremely seriously there's large
dramatic conversations where people
actually have dialogue that has meaning
the action scenes feel real they feel
grounded they actually feel as if Logan
can get hurt which he can in this film
when he sticks his claws into somebody
and pulls them out there's blood on them
they don't hold back in this movie this
movie was really violent for a pg-13 it
was really on the edge
they got away with a lot of things and I
really thought this movie was pretty
freakin awesome I'll put it this way I'm
not gonna relate this film to the
quality of Batman Begins but the first
time I saw Batman Begins I said that is
Batman
they got him right this film is not as
good as Batman Begins but this is the
first time where I've been like that is
Wolverine
perfect they got him right excellent but
there's also a really great sense of the
Japanese culture in there with the
samurais and their culture and their
tendencies and all just really felt like
it meshed with the character of
Wolverine he was trying to become the
Wolverine again he wasn't sure who he
was anymore he goes by Logan and this
film without telling his origin story
tells a much more interesting origin
story in which he learns to be the
person he already was again James
Mangold director
with a great intensity with terrific
stunt work you can see that things are
actually happening actors are doing real
stunts the fight scenes are fast paced
well shot and very realistic there are
aspects of the film that really felt
like how but like I said the reason I
really dug this movie was the
unconventional way of telling it this is
a very straightforward dramatic film
until the last 30 minutes or so which
I'll get to later but for the most part
this movie really is a very
straightforward drama with some terrific
action set-pieces along the way there's
a really good chemistry in a
relationship between Wolverine and the
girl that he's trying to protect and I
really liked how that was built the
dialogue scenes they had Hugh Jackman
dominated as Wolverine in this movie he
just really came through as that
hardened badass this is a guy that's
wounded he's twisted about his past he
has nightmares like every single night
and I really felt like they got the
character right in this film but it was
also just a really exciting film with a
great score by Marco Beltrami really
terrific fight scenes pretty good 3d I
wouldn't say it's necessary to see the
film in 3d it looked fine there wasn't
anything wrong about it it's just you
don't really need to see the film in 3d
I don't think my only issues that I had
with the Wolverine were some aspects of
the final act it does get very
comic-book ish in the last 20 minutes or
so and it's sort of broke from the
tradition that the film was leading up
until then it was almost like they were
like okay we have to have some really
big over-the-top scenes in this movie at
some point that are very comic book ish
otherwise people are gonna get really
pissed and some aspects of one of the
film's villains this girl who could
poison people with her tongue
didn't really like her character that
much it's not that I didn't like her
character because she was evil I just
didn't really feel like she was a strong
villain but the strongest parts of this
movie are Hugh Jackman's performance the
use of the location of Japan the
mythology behind the samurai and how all
of that really felt almost religious the
Wolverine is a really badass movie that
up until the last 20 minutes I had
literally no problems with and even the
last 20 minutes were still really
entertaining and really well directed
even though they broke from the more
serious tradition of the rest of the
film a great action film it looks
terrific good performances I'm gonna
give the Wolverine an A - it really
surprised me if you guys see the film
this weekend let me know what you
thought of it I'm gonna be doing a
spoiler filled review as well later this
weekend also I was so happy to see that
a pretty cool guy on YouTube made a
speedpaint drawing of me as Wolverine I
put a link to that in the description I
thought that was really awesome I was
just watching it laughing with joy my
girlfriend really liked it too and she
wants me to have that body and I'm
working on it I'm working on it Hugh
Jackman inspires me actually that dude
his cut
good job Hugh Jackman so guys thanks as
always for watching I like to know what
is your favorite x-men film so far as
always guys if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]